Mama's with us in New York City hey Tom
merry Christmas to you Merry Christmas a
great how can we help I have a high
school team she just got accepted to her
choice college early decision we're
really proud of her
cool we've done a fairly good job of
knocking away money for her college in a
529 but we're going to be a bit short we
project it's going to be about a hundred
thousand over the four years and we've
got in the 529 just overseas so my
question is do we cash flow the rest
either on the front end back end or just
along the way telling me after this
question a hundred thousand dollars to
go to school sounds like she's going out
of state or to a private college what
what is she going is that the case no
it's our premier in school it's a little
bit expensive okay with you okay okay
okay
and what does you want to major in
marketing communications okay right and
what's your income yeah
household income is about two and a
quarter okay so you can handle the 40
easily yeah deficit and so I'm probably
handling it off the back I'm probably
going to use the hundred for the first
few years that's in the five twenty
unused it up but that and that gives you
basically four years to save up 40 grand
making two and a quarter yeah my monthly
contributions at this point aren't going
to add up to much so I should just set
it aside and saving myself sock it away
yeah yeah and let's use up but let's
burn through the 529 first that's sixty
and knowing that we've got to have the
target of having the other forty sitting
there by the time that happens yeah and
then time as well that's why I agree
with Dave doing it on the back end but
make sure on the back end on the front
end your daughter is actually looking up
scholarships and grants while she's in
school because it sounds like your
daughter is a very smart young lady so
she can secure some scholarships have
her check out my scholarly and raised me
my scholarly comment ray
taught me she'll find some great
scholarships there to wear that for tea
may come down to 20,000 over the next
two years while she's in school and
that's a great Mariano's might come down
to zero yeah and yeah because she's
obviously bright I mean she's had a
tough to get in school and has gotten in
yeah yeah and that that might really
open up some pretty serious doors the
other thing I just take a run to the
school and see what they'll do come on
dad yeah because they you know yeah you
let her in but now what are you paying
yeah because they they do
yeah they regularly do and they don't if
you don't ask that's also worse the
worst answer you could possibly get on
applying for scholarships are asking the
school there's no yeah they won't throw
her out they won't look down out or
anything like that so yeah I'm gonna
poke around on that and see what she can
get and try to try to cover the other
forty but you've definitely got three
years save up forty grand which is a
no-brainer making the kind of money
you're making you're in good shape so it
sounds like you've done a great job
congratulations
and you know you know a Dave something
at while I'm on the road Dave you myself
and Hogan when the first questions I'm
asked that smart money is will a 529 or
ESA really helped me $60,000 will
definitely help you so America I hope
you're listening this this guy started
early he started investing into his
child's future earlier on and yes it
will help you so invest as early as you
can
exactly exactly it's a big deal and you
know school choice and then they picked
out a fairly reasonable school yeah got
a great great degree selection marketing
you're gonna go you know you're not
getting a degree in left handed puppetry
so there's a lot of good things going on
in that call right there very well done
tom